[Musica]
noi tutti siamo convinti di avere sotto
gli occhi la realtà che ci circonda e di
essere quindi convinti di sapere
distinguere qualcosa che è vero da
qualcosa che è falso
pensiamo di poterci fidare della nostra
capacità di giudizio della nostra
memoria della nostra percezione ma siamo
sicuri che sia davvero così hanno andate
le braccia davanti a voi fate
esattamente quello che vi dico
bravissimi
adesso sollevate indici non sono i
pollici quelli va bene i pollici
l'accordo
adesso fate così abbassate le mani
portate la mano destra sopra la sinistra
e incrociate le dita lasciate fuori solo
gli indici e se la vostra capacità di
osservazione funziona a dovere dovreste
essere in grado di fare così e invece
non ci riuscite
come mai perché la realtà è un po più
complessa di quello che sembra
sapete avete senz'altro sentito dire che
viviamo nell'epoca della post verità è
una definizione che francamente non mi
convince molto proprio perché come dire
dà per scontato che ci fosse una volta
un tempo in cui la verità regnava
sovrana è in realtà non c'è mai stato da
quando esiste un uomo esiste la menzogna
la disinformazione e la propaganda
pensate che nel impero romano
l'imperatore che poi sarebbe diventato
ottaviano augusto utilizzava per
screditare il suo rivale marco antonio
dei brevi slogan incise sulle monete
dell'impero un po come i tweet del
presidente trump e questo lo ha aiutato
a diventare effettivamente il primo
imperatore di roma nel medioevo andavano
invece di moda le
i falsi documenti più famoso dei quali
forse proprio la donazione di costantino
che sosteneva che l'imperatore avrebbe
donato alla chiesa la roma e il dominio
su tutto l'impero d'occidente
quando c'è stata l'invenzione della
stampa hanno iniziato a circolare
libercoli pubblicazioni di ogni tipo per
diffamare i propri nemici
la stessa cosa è successa poi con
l'arrivo del cinema della radio della
televisione oggi succede con il web e
questo ci aiuta a capire che sono l'uomo
utilizza da sempre gli strumenti di cui
dispone per diffondere le sue bugie ma
ridimensiona anche l'idea che sia colpa
del web se esistono le [ __ ] news
non è colpa del web anche se certo
contribuisce a diffonderle come fa
qualunque mezzo di comunicazione di
massa del resto la differenza è che lo
fa una velocità tale che non si era mai
vista prima e quindi diventa molto
difficile smontare le bufale perché una
volta che arriva la smentita i danni
creati dalla far monia ormai sono già
dilaganti allora il problema diventa
anche un altro ex mentre noi vediamo una
competizione costante nel mondo
dell'informazione tra la necessità di
attenerci ai fatti e la tendenza invece
a inseguire il sensazionalismo perché
chiaramente attira più facilmente
ascolti e pubblico una battaglia analoga
si svolge nella nostra mente tra il
tentativo insomma di avere il controllo
della della nostra mente tra la
razionalità e tra invece l'istinto e il
premio nobel daniel cane ma parla
proprio a questo proposito di pensieri
lenti quelli razionali quelli un po più
impegnativi e pensieri veloci quelli
veloci quelli fisici emotivi quell
istintivi che partono in vantaggio che
quindi hanno più facilità di portarci a
interpretare le cose in maniera errata
allora che cosa succede che noi ci
troviamo a cercare conferme alle nostre
convenzioni cerchiamo rassicurazioni 10
sono tantissimi altri errori cognitivi
nei quali possiamo cadere cercando alla
fine di trovare solamente quelle bugie
che ci confortano ignorando
tutti fatti contrari quindi quelle
verità scomode che invece ci troviamo
sempre di fronte come si fa allora a
diventare più più dubbiosi come si fa a
esercitare l'arte del dubbio come si fa
a non cadere negli inganni non solo che
ci arrivano dall informazione ma anche
quelli che la nostra mente abbiamo visto
prima che non ci possiamo fidare tanto
della percezione ma anche i nostri
ragionamenti ci possono trarre in errore
il primo suggerimento è quello di essere
scettici che cosa significa il metodo
scientifico proprio l'esempio più più
bello insomma migliore per farci capire
come essere scettici ci può per me
permettere di fare dei progressi il
progresso scientifico e proprio basato
sulla necessità di mettere in
discussione un i conoscenze acquisite ma
attenzione essere scettici non vuol dire
dubitare di tutto e soprattutto non vuol
dire bollare come falso quello che non
ci piace semplicemente vuol dire che di
fronte alle informazioni
noi dobbiamo essere consapevoli che
possono essere vere o false
bisogna allora andare a verificare
questo ci porta al secondo punto come si
fa a verificare un informazione
il primo passo da compiere quello di
risalire alle fonti chi ha detto questa
cosa se ci pensate ma quando portato il
cibo sul tavolo vi chiedete da dove
arrivano a questa roba e sarà fresca
avrà seguito tutte le norme d'igiene
insomma non vogliamo mangiare schifezze
giusto perché dovremmo fare invece
qualcosa di diverso con le informazioni
che mettiamo nel nostro cervello
dobbiamo proprio abituarci a pensare a
farci questo tipo di domande da dove
arrivano queste informazioni saranno
complete o qualcuno l'avrà alterate la
fonte che ce le diffonde sincero
potrebbe avere dei secondi motivi dei
secondi fini per dircelo in un certo
modo è sempre stata credibile questa
fonte questo tipo di domande ci aiuta
sicuramente ad avere una visione più
chiara sulle informazioni che riceviamo
il terzo consiglio quello di aspettare
prima di reagire perché è proprio quando
le emozioni sono forti che rischiamo
veramente di sbagliare se una notizia ci
fa arrabbiare
o magari ci esalta perché va a
confermare quelle che sono le nostre
credenze il momento di fermarci e di
riflettere di andare a fare altre
ricerche e di verificare il rischio
altrimenti è quello di iniziare a
diffondere a condividere cose che non
sono vere
proprio come in un pasto voi alla fine
del pasto prima di mangiare
qualcos'altro di vedere sia spazio
ancora per qualcosa vi fermate un attimo
e ci pensa te lo stesso va fatto con le
notizie prima di diffonderle
condividerle
fate attenzione alle correlazioni
illusorie cosa significa che quando
accadono due fatti contemporaneamente
non significa necessariamente che sono
legati da una correlazione di causa
effetto passa un gatto nero e subito
dopo noi inciampiamo pensare che
l'inciampo sia colpa del gatto è un
errore perché non c'è una relazione di
causa effetto è una superstizione ma il
nostro cervello è portato proprio a
cercare delle correlazioni anche quando
non ci sono e quindi pensiamoci bene
prima di pensare prima di credere di
aver trovato un legame tra due fatti del
tutto scollegati
il quinto punto è quello di non
limitarsi a cercare solo conferme alle
cose che che vorremmo sentirci dire non
chiudiamoci in quelle bolle in quelle
camere dell'eco come si dice dove
sentiamo rimbalzare solamente opinioni
come la nostra sia una la vita reale che
sui social è importante sentire anche
opinioni diverse il che non vuol dire
che dobbiamo andare d'accordo su tutto e
non vuol dire che ci dobbiamo bere tutto
quello che ci viene raccontato
ma come in una dieta sana ancora una
volta è bene avere una varietà di
informazioni sul nostro piatto e per
finire ancora due consigli sempre utili
quando si va a indagare qualcosa o ad
ascoltare o ad affrontare qualche
affermazione è incredibile e quindi
vorremmo andarci con i piedi di piombo
la prima è che sia una storia sembra
troppo bella per essere vera anche se ci
piacerebbe molto che fosse vera quasi
sicuramente non lo è
come diceva carl sagan di fronte
all'affermazione straordinarie
sono necessarie prove straordinarie e
l'ultimo consiglio e quello per cui di
fronte a notizie nuove che potrebbe in
qualche modo cambiare anche la nostra
percezione è sempre importante avere una
mente aperta ma non così aperta che il
cervello caschi per terra grazie
[Applauso]